if you don't allow them to change and
you still [ __ ] on them for stuff that
they used to do why change right why not
stick to the same [ __ ] that you always
do if you do not accept the the path
that they took to become better they
might as well just do the same [ __ ] and
that's what's happening oh if you're
gonna [ __ ] on me for this word that I
said or the things that I've done that
I've already apologized for that I
decisively decided in my life to change
about myself but you still hate me for
it then [ __ ] it then I guess I'm gonna
be the same and I've seen that in five
four three two one I realized
welcome to a genius of brain accordion a
podcast
I would love to do a podcast in all
Korean if I my Korean was full enough
but I can't do it I think I'd look like
an idiot hey dumbfounded did a podcast
in all Korean once really he had a bunch
of uh I guess like other Korean
musicians on it and this full screen is
trash so did he have to put subtitles no
I'm listening to speak Korean like I
wanted to kill myself I was like Jesus
Christ man like you think your korean's
bad his cream is [ __ ] terrible man I
speak like baby conglish it's just the
way I grew up yeah I mean that's how
well I thought he could speak Korean a
lot better just because he grew up in
K-Town not the case absolutely not the
case he's probably gotten a lot better
though because he's been to Korea so
much but that was actually pretty
surprised how bad his Korean was I got I
was very proud of mine at the time I was
like oh [ __ ] not as bad as I thought it
was but a lot of Korean Americans are
like that though
um when I first met Muriel and I told
her that I could speak Korean a little
bit she was like she actually was like
fairly surprised because she was like oh
yeah you could speak Korean and then
when we did this you know the the
sketches together she was like oh you
can't speak Korean I'm like what do you
mean she goes most most of the people
that I've met that lived in La unless
they were like either born in Korea yeah
they can't really speak Korean and she
heard me speak Korean to my mom
and she was shocked that I could
actually speak yeah she goes oh you know
how to even say numbers she was talking
to me like I was an idiot but I have to
do numbers I have to like count uh look
out with my fingers and [ __ ] you know
what was the worst is that uh Dan and I
went to Korea together and so our friend
Dan he's half white half Korean but he
looks full white right and so when we
went to Korea together Dan was relying
on me to like have to speak Korean and
then I'm sitting there with these cream
but then when I'm with Korean people in
Korea different it's different and I
start to sweat I'm like uh uh the thing
with Dan though is that he has like a
minimal baby like Korean too right yeah
but when I try to speak Korean in Korea
I'm an idiot yeah you know
look at me like this yeah
but then when Dan had to just try to
speak for himself they love it they love
him for speaking Korean and then the
white guy yeah the white guy speaking
Korean I would have outed him
every time he tells people he's half
Korean people don't believe him okay he
looks straight white yeah yeah but he's
Korean as [ __ ] yeah like he's more
Korean everything on the inside is so
Korean yeah the funniest one that you
told me was the thing in the elevator
so yeah we're there was uh what's it
there's that it was like a pretty famous
uh norabang in K-Town it was like on the
top floor of some um mall or Plaza and
then you know we're all leaving it's
like I don't know 2 A.M or some [ __ ] 4
a.m and um so everybody's got to go and
then the elevators packed and then
Dan's is drunk and then uh so because
it's so packed the elevated doors
wouldn't close because Dan's butt was
standing in the way he had his back
facing it and then was like
it goes oh oops sorry
and he's like sorry guys sorry everyone
and then this Korean girl was sitting in
the back like
yeah right and Dan looks at her and goes
do you guys
laughs
he's like you're being loud you [ __ ] so
it feels so [ __ ] embarrassed and
everyone else in the elevator was
cracking up at this girl
oh my god dude that is so with dad's
truck he is so [ __ ] funny dude and
you know in K-Town too like We'll always
have him order because all the actions
and Nemo's they love him and then they
hook it up because there's cute Korean
guys yeah
you know when I went to Korea man like
it's it's crazy how uh accommodating
accommodating they are to like
westerners because all the street names
in Korea now they all have uh the
English translation in the bottom all
right it's all romanized it's all
romanized because of the military
presence right yeah every [ __ ] street
so if you if you are looking for a place
to be at you don't know what the street
if somebody tells you in Korea you could
actually just see the romanized version
yeah in English so you could actually
get around it's very very accommodating
to people who are are not from there
which I'm really surprised it's like
it's it's kind of nice yeah and then
those streets aren't like blocks you
know they're like spaghetti streets yeah
and the cool thing about Muriel is like
because Muriel lived in Korea and her
you know her Korean is really [ __ ]
good like like when I when I heard her
speak Korean already it's way way better
than mine right and then in Korea
because she was only speaking it all the
time it got better and better and better
and at to a certain point where they
didn't even realize that she was from
the states right but they could tell I'm
from the states immediately right I know
every time I would talk they would just
look at her I'm like okay I think
there's a thing like um my friend had
some kind of I forget if it was like a
biology class or something but um it was
like Asian Americans who grow up in
America actually start looking different
than Asians in Asia really because of
our languages we speak the way our
tongue develops changes our facial
structure the the emotions we emote
because it's the American style it
changes the muscles in our face dude
Korean people in Korea look different
than us yeah they look way different
yeah I'm like look at you gooks dude
until you meet a girl who's been to the
kangnam plastic surgery they all look
alike it's hard to like it's hard to
pinpoint like yo like yeah I don't say
all Koreans look alike but what do you
guys do that one of the coolest things
that I saw in Korea from the difference
that I saw
um from when I was 14 years old when I
was 14 I specifically remember how
homogeneous society was yeah everybody
looked the same everybody dressed the
same and they're still like that to a
certain extent right but we have that
here too where everybody does their
makeup the same or whatever
um but when I was there all the clothing
styles were a little different so yeah
there's certain things that are hot
right now so right now the hottest thing
that I've seen with young people because
I was out in um not Busan or uh not not
nothing African um what's it called it's
like the popping spot right for all the
young people all the college students
yeah universities right there
is everybody stressing like [ __ ] John
Travolta in Greece Greece that's the
hottest thing so it's like the rolled up
uh black shirt yeah gold chain like
baggy pants they put their cigarette in
their sleeves basically oh my God yeah
and then when they walk around with
their girls they do it like in the old
50s 60s with the arms over the girl oh
my God I was tripping out I'm like yo so
this is like the hot thing but they
still that's the cool thing to do right
now but everybody still has like their
own individual style right which is very
cool and I think it's like the onset of
the internet where people get the
Pikachu social media yeah yeah they
start seeing a lot more fashion [ __ ]
coming through different Instagram like
and they can you know choose to be
different I mean in a homogenized
Society yeah you want to stand out it's
kind of like in Japan too right because
like everybody typically like looks the
same day
they try very hard to like stand out
right in Japan I noticed that too like
um in in Korea that when the last time
we went was like 2009 that was a while
ago but yeah it was like wow everybody
kind of looks the same at that time like
you'd see so many girls wearing a
flannel like long sleeve flannel shirts
and then typically not when I see that
they're like the Christian girls
it's like the modest
modest look I remember just
just go in there too one of the things
that I always I feel like it was good
for me to go to Korea because I got to
see stuff that was outside of just what
we see in Korean media and and I think
I've been very hyper critical
specifically because
how do I say this I I dislike one of the
things that maybe I dislike about the
culture that we're from is the idea that
we always have to change and just mangle
our face to fit a western ideal of what
beauty is and that [ __ ] [ __ ] hurts me
every time that I see it yeah
um you don't see that as much in like
Korea everybody looks a little different
and you know obviously the makeup's the
same and you know guys are wearing you
know their Foundation or whatever that's
fine but when we see it in Korean media
these people don't look human right and
they are supposed to be the
representation of what they believe is
idealistically beautiful but they're
following what western Trends are and
you know Western people are beautiful in
their own way but we have our own set of
beauty too and we should have our own
standards but yeah we keep looking
towards this western style of bigger
eyes sharper nose you know a [ __ ] V10
the V10 you know that's why we have you
know all these miss koreas that look
exactly the same oh my gosh did you see
that uh GIF where it's like or GIF I
guess where it's the miscarriage career
contestants and then it Cycles through
them like one frame each and this just
looks like the same exact person it's
[ __ ] crazy crazy like how do you
select Miss Korea if they're all the
same yeah exactly because I just pick
the one that would look like the other
one yeah there's this there's a show
that Mario's watching it's like a dating
show in Korea where Partners Swift they
swap partners and they're obviously
selecting people who are going to be
exciting entertaining or whatever but
every single girl had an immense amount
of plastic surgery to my face and I'm
looking at them it's like dude you took
the humanness away from who you are like
somebody told you or you were not so
much forced to believe but you you kind
of had this idea that you're you're not
beautiful right like the face that you
were given isn't beautiful
and I'm pretty and I've seen like photos
of other celebrities when they were
younger and they were freaking pretty
that they had a they were pressured into
looking like this look dude have you
seen that girl from that uh band uh 21
um which one dude let me let me let me
look up her name and Robin couch will
find her for you
by the way every podcast you are going
to hear me say Robin couch because she
is the [ __ ] and we have fact Checkers
here yeah finally which is where we [ __ ]
up
hey Robin can you look up uh p-a-r-k
space b-o-m
sorry spell that again
p-a-r-k space b-o-m
yeah and so this is a really popular
group uh you guys may have heard of this
girl named CL she was like the rapper
she actually had a debut in the states
[ __ ] amazing she just she just played
uh Coachella and then they had a reunion
21 reasons that's amazing yeah but you
look at this girl pop bomb her face is
nuts look no disrespect to her right I
understand but she has gotten addicted
to
to plastic surgery she does not look
human anymore and I look at that and
every time she you know debuts or
whatever you see her face change again
and again
um so oh man she doesn't look like I
mean like I went to one of their
concerts back in oh back in 2012. oh
shoot if you see a picture of her face
before she was adorable yeah yeah but
she got addicted to the plastic surgery
thing and she stopped looking human yeah
yeah how [ __ ] nuts is that yeah I
guess like when if you're getting older
and older
oh my gosh like
um what is it called uh dysmorphia yeah
body dysmorphia dysmorphia yeah they
just keep I mean like we see it in
Beverly Hills with all these older white
ones what was wrong with the previous
face yeah nothing
absolutely nothing but you can't
convince people otherwise that they're
beautiful if they don't feel it inside
yeah you know and I think sometimes too
I think a lot of Korean people have to
understand this like
you know you are responsible for this
Youth and how they feel about themselves
because you are the the litmus test or
the indicator for what they believe is a
center Beauty standard yeah and we see
that so much in like Korean Society
and it starts to eat me up a little bit
so when I hear like some of my friends
they go I want to do this just age you
are supposed to age your face is
supposed to change it's [ __ ] okay
yeah you're kind of like investing into
something that's very fleeting I
actually uh edited a short Doc on
plastic surgery in Korea oh really yeah
yeah
um and to be honest when they do minimal
work like it looks great like especially
when they get older like okay so like
what I mean about like that La look
these older white women that or even
white people like my cats they look like
cats like with their straight if their
face stretched back right and then I saw
this picture of this uh white lady who
went to Korea to get work done like an
older like lady and she looked great
because it was very minimal but then
damn there's a place where you cross the
line like yeah where you look like a cat
you look like a weird anime character
that just is it's not human anymore yeah
yeah and then
I know what you're talking about too
because um there's a friend of mine who
has been getting BOTOX for years and I
just didn't know yeah and she's been
doing it so subtly and minimally just to
get rid of Fine Lines right you just
would have never known yeah I would have
never [ __ ] known and once again your
face your body do whatever the [ __ ] you
want right it's just my opinion about
how it kind of affects women's
um perception of themselves like they
don't want to age like you never want to
eat and I I get it like you know as I
get older too I'm noticing the bags and
you know the circles the fine lines or
whatever but it's okay yeah like I mean
I mean like Sylvester Stallone these
days too is like oh what's what's wrong
with your eyebrows yeah
you go Sly what happened yeah you know
it's just a weird perception that I've
seen in you know I think
what I've seen online is that there's
like this shift of before it was this
movement of telling uh this Young
Generation that ate
you're beautiful the way that you are
you know find the things that you love
about yourself and focus on that and the
differences is kind of what makes
everybody beautiful if everybody looked
exactly the same you have nothing to
bounce off of like the the American
sweet 16 thing is like oh getting a car
right in Korea like nobody has cars
anymore right so it's like I'm you keep
seeing different docs like all sorts of
people who interview high school kids
and they're all looking forward to their
plastic surgery all of them are looking
forward to getting work done and that's
so wild but then in that Society it's
completely acceptable accepted like man
that's so wild like it kind of hurts
yeah as a Korean person to be like dude
it's this is you this is us like this is
what we look like yeah it's not even
just accept what you have it's more like
no what you have is [ __ ] beautiful
yeah you have fooled yourself into
believing that somebody else's standards
of what Something Beautiful is is what
you should base your life on but it's
also leaking into other countries like
the Phil Philippines Thailand and like
Indonesia they start coming to Korea and
then they want to get this it's it's not
like they want to look Korean they want
to get the plastic surgery Korean look
yeah yeah let's see and this is why I
also understand why there was a movement
in like the black community a black is
beautiful yeah because people have been
told for so long that the darker your
skin the uglier you are yeah but it's
you know you're gonna be like yo cookie
is beautiful yeah dude is beautiful
model it is beautiful dude yeah and you
know what trends will change yeah Trends
always change man after a while people
like oh maybe I don't like the double
eyelid maybe I want the single one it's
like well what happened I thought this
was the standard for what you thought
beauty was but that stuff always shifts
and change so I I understand now even
more so why people fight this idea of
you know the more lighter skin that you
have the more beautiful that you are
because imagine like like what black
Americans had to deal with their whole
life yeah you know especially like women
too there's a reason why like even um
like the black American woman experience
with their hair their hair yeah you know
like I had friends who told me like I
remember when I was a kid if if I went
outside and uh
I didn't put a flat iron to my hair I
didn't flatten out my hair I didn't gel
it up I didn't put my hair in a ponytail
or whatever like my my aunt would be
like you're not walking out like that oh
your mom would be like you're not
walking out like that you gotta look
presentable or some [ __ ] right right but
that's like stuff that was taught to
them like your hair is also just
beautiful yeah there's no like
celebration of individuality anymore
even though people say don't judge me
and like you know don't I'm Different no
you're not you're exactly the same and
you know you got to pick what side of
the fence are you on you know what I
mean like are you celebrating your
individuality or are you trying to be
like everybody else you can't have both
you know it doesn't make any sense yeah
yeah maybe we need a movement too for
Koreans to accept themselves for what
they look like and who they are yeah
yeah like if that movement never comes
around I'm all for it like have you have
you even felt too like I feel like as
I've gotten older
um I become more and more Korean
like for me um like because I had a
massive uh physical change because I
lost so much weight like one thing that
happened was that I got sung of her oh I
got double eyelids but that's because I
lost weight that's you've always had it
you just never yeah I've always had it
it's just like I was just you know
overweight like 100 pounds overweight I
have a penis yeah
oh but what we wanted to talk about
today was uh it's a very interesting
subject because it's kind of something
that's kind of personal and close to us
right specifically because uh Ed and I
have uh ran our parents businesses
before and we've also been a part of the
small business Community specifically
that a lot of Asian Americans are a part
of right and um there was a video that
was going around that was
to me was extremely polarizing in the
sense that I was actually surprised by
the reaction that people had when they
saw this video right specifically in the
Asian American Community yeah
um this video uh popped up on Twitter
for me and it was a vape store out in
Vegas right yeah it was a vape store out
in Vegas it was a young Asian man that
was running the store I'm not sure it
was a family-owned business if it was
his I think it was his business and uh
two people came in masked yeah and they
came in to rob the Vapes the cartridges
or whatever yeah right they didn't go
for the register or anything else like
that but I'm not trying to put my bias
into it but essentially he said that he
was fearing for his life he had a knife
and it was probably one of the most
horrific things I've ever seen it was
disgusting flat out like we shouldn't be
watching that stuff it was
kind of traumatizing for me but it was
the kid who posted it himself on his
Instagram
like oh he posted it himself he put it
out there
like he was proud of what he had done
that's what disturbs me yeah and so like
what's what what happens was like one
kid snatches something and he runs out
the door the other kid jumps the counter
and so the Asian American guy he goes
the opposite direction for a second and
grabs a knife it's like a six inch blade
crazy and he goes straight for him and
like he stabs him like seven times
in his body and his back and through his
neck I have never seen something so
[ __ ] vicious in my life and um
here's like we're gonna expand on this
right but just to give you my initial
initial thoughts when I heard that kid
say I'm dead bro I'm dead yeah that [ __ ]
[ __ ] wrecked me and I was like
because I listen I have been in a my
parents have a business right and we've
had terrible situations that have
happened like this where people have
tried to steal stuff swipe things or
whatever and
my opinion and a topic on this was very
different from a lot of people in the
Asia Community they said he deserved it
yeah I I can't believe it I could not
believe that I and this is for from a
lot of people who have never been in
this position before I have been in this
position I have never ever thought about
stabbing somebody to death oh I've been
in that position very recently too and
like when I put it out there on my
social media like saying this is
disgusting it's unnerving this is not
right I got I get DMs like this is the
majority of people support him and that
kind of that set me off the edge like
what the [ __ ] do you mean the maturity
like how is it that the majority of
people watching this support murder yeah
murder over some [ __ ] paper some Vape
some cartridges so let me like
I understand what they're going they're
like well you know you get tired of this
happening to you over and over again to
your store right like you get tired of
being bullied you're getting robbed or
whatever and you know albeit for him he
could have said that you know I actually
feared for my life I understand all
these things right once again I have
been in these positions before right my
parents store was not in a very good
neighborhood yeah um I have stories and
stories of of it didn't happen often but
when it did it was pretty scary right
people have tried to steal from us grab
stuff swipe it run away
at the end of the day do I value this
product that costs a few dollars maybe
even a hundred dollars over human life
right I do not agree with that I agree
that somebody has to defend themselves I
agree that in those situations they go
well you haven't been in that situation
sorry you stupid [ __ ] I have
been in that situation I have never ever
in my life thought about stabbing
somebody in the [ __ ] neck that part
he killed him like he was [ __ ] cattle
he's alive he'll he survived oh my God
thank God I thought you died but the
other I think the other part of the
story is like he stabbed him in the
spine and that's why his legs went limp
so now he's paralyzed from the waistline
people were like well that's what you
deserve no [ __ ] that dude no I I can't
agree with that here's the listen
it ah they were running away yeah he was
going to grab it and run yeah I've had
situations in my story people are twice
that we just let them run away yeah
because it's not worth it it's not worth
my life it's not worth these products
when you when you Val when you're
valuing your personal emotions about how
you feel about getting bullied to take
somebody's life away there is some
intensive therapy that you need right
also too the reason why I say that is
because I know plenty of people that
I've that I've known that I've grown up
with that were pieces of [ __ ] yeah right
yeah guess what they are now pharmacists
doctors dude I was at a [ __ ] wedding
and I told the story before on this
podcast where there was this guy that I
specifically remember his older brother
who was a highly Affiliated gang member
put a gun to my [ __ ] dick because I
made a joke at him yeah yeah right he's
a pharmacist now he's he's now saving
lives yeah
he's giving out Viagra now I'm not
trying to shoot off
you know yeah we had this we
did that people will be the way that
they are for the rest of their lives and
honestly them stealing Vapes is nothing
they'd even go for the register they
didn't go for the money they didn't pull
a gun he even offered the money and they
didn't go for the money yeah and it's
like they went off after some of these
products it's like you know these guys
have a nicotine addiction
like like you you'll live another day
and and like
you know what I I kept trying to follow
up with the story and this [ __ ]
did a Reddit AMA Jesus Christ see this
is what I'm talking about [ __ ] nuts
you took a selfie to verify himself and
then you start reading his answers he's
a [ __ ] dumbass yeah all of the
comments in this AMA is like dude delete
this you [ __ ] idiot like everything
you're saying loves it he loves you
intimidating yourself yes he was craving
the attention for what he had done
that's [ __ ] sick yeah that is not
right if you think that's okay in this
Society like we're [ __ ] especially all
the people who say that this was
justified Jesus Christ you know who are
the people who are saying that are
people who haven't been behind a [ __ ]
register yeah it's all these people who
have been scrolling through their videos
watching whether it's you know you know
next shark does what it can for our
community you know but then there's some
of these you know Instagram pages and
and whatever like Asian Dawn or Asian
With Attitudes or whatever and you start
reading through the comments he deserved
it he got what he was coming to him you
know what that is that's vicarious PTSD
because these pages keep showing you
Asians being [ __ ] you know attacked
Asians being assaulted and Asians being
robbed all these things yes we need to
put the word out there right but then
you also as a viewer need to assess
where you are and who you are in this
situation because it's not happening to
you yeah but you're getting a vicarious
PTSD by watching something horrible and
now inside you feel all of this hate and
you need all of this Vengeance and all
this [ __ ] then you're not handling
yourself in a situation and your own
reality you're only watching the most
terrible things and You Want Blood and
so you see this kid do something that
you fantasize about doing that this kid
probably fantasized about doing because
he was watching all these [ __ ] videos
he was waiting waiting for it man and
like I said you and I have been in this
situation I've told the story before
about the guy who who stole a case of
beer and I was at my age too and I was
like you know what [ __ ] this I'm gonna
stop it I'm gonna tell the story again
I'm not gonna tell it from the whole
court side yeah opinion of you I'm just
gonna say what happened like I I
followed him out he was drunk as [ __ ] he
stole our most expensive case of beer
still 22 bucks yeah you know after all
that happened like I really in the end
didn't think it was really worth it for
what had happened even for him
um I stopped him from getting back in
his car I wrestled him down I did
everything to subdue him I didn't like
beat the [ __ ] out of him out of him like
up front I put him in a rear naked joke
you know uh he fell asleep for a few
seconds so I can go grab a phone and
call 9-1-1 and when I got back up he uh
when I came back out he was up again
trying to get back in his car
and
so I put him down again you know and to
the point where he was struggling with
me so much I put my knee on his his
chest and then he [ __ ] grabbed my
dick
he grabbed my dick now right there even
then I wasn't like oh I'm gonna stab
this [ __ ] yeah no I threw my
elbow at him and I cut his his it cut
his eye open you know like I didn't need
a knife to cut him in a sense but I
needed him to stop grabbing my dick yeah
and then when he fell over and then I
tried to subdue him again he grabbed my
dick a second time
and that's when I if I only move on now
yeah so I had the fun I had 9-1-1 you
know on dial and then I said excuse me I
had to I have to put this phone down and
then I [ __ ] punched him out yeah
punched him out until he was subdued I
didn't need to make sure he was down by
stabbing him until he was bleeding out
so he thought he was just dead where he
was like I'm dead here's like the
important part of this too it's like the
emotion that you felt after it wasn't
[ __ ] yeah I beat the [ __ ] out of this
guy he deserved it
on a [ __ ] Reddit am AMA just loving
it you know what he said dude like
people are like man like what was it
like in the moment he said because of
his experience playing League of Legends
[ __ ] PC games
that his heart rate like he's trained
like high stress situations and his
heart rate was high but then he kept
this cool because he plays League of
Legends he's a psychopath that's [ __ ]
psychotic and idiotic like you support
this my fellow Asian American brethrens
like like seriously that's what I'm
saying like
what I was so shocked to read the
comments saying he got what he deserved
like do you have any idea how
frightening and visceral it is to stab
something to death most of you won't
even cut the head of a fish off before
you eat it the [ __ ] are you talking
about you [ __ ] Psychopaths I've
always learned to like from people like
whether it's military or whatever like
you know shooting a gun at somebody is
way easier than holding a knife and
feeling it going to somebody's body and
he did hating somebody six or seven
times yeah when I saw him go for the
neck I'm like he's a he's a he needs to
go crazy he either needs to he needs to
be in a psych ward or he needs to go to
jail or he should have joined the
military you know that's if you feel
like you need to support your property
like some [ __ ] you know Vapes you
know hey try use that passion to protect
his country bro you know that's that's
just crazy and the problem with this too
is like you know I read a lot of like
racist comments too and that [ __ ]
[ __ ] killed me too like you know I
don't I don't know what the ethnicity
was but I think the young kid was was he
black uh no they were white they were
white yeah Big Talk I Read comments too
they were talking the reason why I
thought they were black because they
were saying some [ __ ] like some that
they were like assuming that well black
people would Rob these things yeah like
um those are white people yeah that was
that that's the always the thing that
kind of like [ __ ] me up all the time
too it's like
um I remember when you know BLM was
really hot and all this stuff was
happening right
a lot of Asian people were [ __ ] upset
at me too they're like well what do you
say about all these black people hurting
Asian people I was like what did you say
about these Asian people black people
then yeah like
you we can't I like I said you know you
made a very poignant point it's like
this trauma porn that they keep watching
and they believe that this is their
experience listen your your personal
experience with whatever Community or
whatever you've had is your experience
right but I also have mine you have to
understand I grew up in a predominantly
black neighborhood right and I've had it
terrible terrible interaction with black
folks too however that was like maybe
one percent yeah that one percent
doesn't take over the 99 of people that
I met in my store that have supported my
parents business they have been still
coming back to this day my parents were
turning customer base is all the money
that they made yeah we didn't have a lot
of new customers if ever at all it was
the same people in the same community
that support us they could have gone
anywhere they could have went to Walmart
it's cheaper they could have gone to the
other store down the street but they
always came back to my parents door so
do I sit there as a terrible person let
this let this a couple of terrible
interactions represent what the the
kindness and Humanity that I felt from
the other people and that's the hard
part that people don't do they get eaten
up by this small part but they forget
all the good stuff that has happened
yeah you know yeah no and I grew up in a
predominantly white rural white you know
like it was unique yeah and so but I'll
be honest like because I've said this
before on the podcast like I started to
see myself becoming a racist against
white people yeah but then I also
realized that I had been traumatized
like I've said if I see a old bald white
man with a goatee I need to [ __ ] go
the other way yeah you know because they
were the ones giving so me so much oh my
God don't go Steve Austin
oh he said oh my God like
um and I I've had and I went to therapy
I signed myself up for therapy because I
was like the biggest thing I hate being
it's one of my worst traits is being a
hypocrite yeah and me treating them the
way they treat me I couldn't accept that
in myself and I saw all the signs of it
yeah and like how does that ever when
has that ever worked you know for you to
generalizing white people or it's all
terrible treat somebody the way that
they treated you and expect things to
get better right and I understand I'm
guilty of this too especially when I was
younger like I I made it a point to be
like oh you're gonna treat me like [ __ ]
I'm gonna treat you like [ __ ] back right
and has never solved anything it just
created bigger hate bigger hate and
bigger hate and I just I just can't
agree with that anymore you know we
can't allow ourselves to let the hate
consume us I know this is some like Jedi
[ __ ] or whatever but it's a real like
Behavioral Health Therapy too like if
you haven't actually been in that
situation you know in reality but you've
been watching trauma porn all [ __ ]
day and night like you are not having a
good grip on the reality of the society
we live in and because of that [ __ ]
getting all the views and all the likes
and all the comments those [ __ ]
Instagram pages are gonna keep feeding
you with trauma porn because you're
gonna run back to it you get that
confirmation bias every time time it's
like oh I knew this is how these people
are yeah
um one of the things too that I'm not
sure if I shared this story too but
you know going back to when I was
talking about how
trying to get listen I'm a very weird
person in the tense in the sense of like
I understand that my identity is a
mixture of everything it's like this
american-ness the you know the black
community that I was a part of and then
also my you know Korean culture because
I wasn't born here yeah so I'm just like
this conglomeration of all this stuff so
I always pay due in respect to a lot of
the cultures that kind of made who I am
today right and it's it's not me on some
woke [ __ ] it's just like no I think it's
dope I I see that
um and so when people come up to me and
they go well you don't I remember I used
to hear it from some of these dweebie
ass [ __ ] Asians like you support the
black could be more than you you're the
Asian Community I was like really do you
know who the [ __ ] I am yeah why can't it
be both yeah why does it like always
Tuesday why is it so binary why is it so
black and white yeah when we call
ourselves Asian Americans like what does
being an American mean to you like we
found that up when we go to Korea like
oh [ __ ] we're so American yeah yeah they
can see it in US yeah but then I also
get from like Korean people in Korea to
hey embrace your koreanness yeah hey
you're Korean you know when you're here
when in Rome you know take your pants
off at the ginger
that's good yeah show me your penis yeah
I want to see according to penis but you
know I'll tell you this really
interesting story and this is kind of
like the the basis of um
like kind of like what [ __ ] is about
right it was the uh
when I was a kid
um
there was this lady that I remember and
she used to scare the [ __ ] out of me
because every time she would come in the
store and she would buy stuff my parents
never kicked her out right because she
was a customer yeah my mom didn't care
whatever she's gonna pay money she's not
really doing anything besides coming in
here with a [ __ ] attitude right
that's fine whatever but I remember this
time where I was getting older my mom's
like listen you gotta learn how to like
watch some of these customers you have
to know who the ones that are looking to
steal share the ones that aren't right
and so there's always like there's
always like young kids that want to
steal [ __ ] and most of the time they
work because they're young they're gonna
do that [ __ ]
so this lady comes in and I'm sitting
there and I'm going over and I'm just
I'm watching her right she looks at me
and she starts [ __ ] ripping into me
she goes you think I'm a [ __ ] steal
[ __ ] like all you [ __ ] like chinks
and you Goofs think you're so much
better than that starts [ __ ] going
off on me and she's like you're bet
you're [ __ ] profit off a [ __ ] all
of our cultures stealing from our
community yeah yeah and she starts
screaming at me and I'm kid I'm like
traumatized as [ __ ] and I don't know
what to say to her right and then
another customer comes in he's like hey
leave this [ __ ] kid alone
um thank God for that Customer because I
was about to cry you know I'm like
[ __ ] 10 11 years old right and I
didn't think I was doing anything wrong
I was like it's our store I'm just
watching customers making sure they're
not doing crazy [ __ ] or that they need
help and she just berates me and I'm
sitting there just traumatized I'm
shaking I'm shaking I'm shaking up well
every time this lady came in she would
stare at me and just look at me like I'm
a piece of [ __ ] and I just every time I
she came in I would just cower away from
her because I was so [ __ ] scared she
was frightening I mean you get yelled at
and chewed up by an adult like that as a
young kid you're just scared of them
yeah so
here's a crazy turning point uh never
told the story but I was uh
I was riding my bike around the
neighborhood we used to live at this
duplex in Sacramento called Tim Woods
Tim Woods at the time I'm not sure how
it is now was [ __ ] bad it was it was
bad there was trap houses every [ __ ]
corner and we lived at this duplex that
was connected to my uh cousin's house
and so we were neighbors we were next to
each other and we were [ __ ] poor a
lot of the times people didn't
understand when they came to the store
because we were business owners they
didn't understand how [ __ ] poor we
were yeah because we were barely making
ends meet and they didn't know that
because all they saw was that this
person owns a business they must be
balling yeah and so I was riding my bike
around and guess who was there the lady
at the store right and I was and she
goes hey
and I look back and I see her and I I
[ __ ] lock up yeah you know I'm
traumatized I'm oh [ __ ] she's gonna
[ __ ] shoot me out she's like what are
you doing here and I go I'm not saying
it she goes
she's being really kind at this point
she goes sweetie what are you doing here
and I'm like I live here yeah she goes
what do you mean you live here I was
like I live right there I'll show you
the house so this is my house
and she was shocked she goes you live in
my neighborhood oh she was like mind
blown I was like yeah like we're poor
I'm tearing up because like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] me up when I was a kid because
like
I remember when I saw her she was like
oh [ __ ] like her voice changed and she
was like you're poor just like me
ever since then treated me so sweet yeah
she accepted you she accepted me and she
didn't understand like dude like we're
strongly every [ __ ] day like I'm
right here I'm your [ __ ] neighbor
I remember as a kid like I didn't
realize that when I was older I was like
[ __ ] these people just don't know us
yeah like they don't get it like yo like
I'm particularly poorer than you and I
remember when she looked at us and she
didn't realize that the we have like
this beat up like Toyota truck and she's
like that's your car
she thought we'd be rolling around like
BMWs
I remember after that moment like she
twist her tune
like a couple weeks after that I was at
the store I was like maybe 12 years old
good morning she was like good morning
how are you doing she said how you doing
how's your baby she called me babies he
would give me candy and [ __ ] yeah yeah
and I I just remember this defining
moment was like oh [ __ ] these people
just don't know us yeah all she could
see was like I'm going through this
struggle every day and these people are
taken from my community yeah and then
she realized at that point like oh this
[ __ ] is poor
these [ __ ] poorest [ __ ] and I just
didn't understand him like I didn't I
thought these guys were just looking at
us because they were looking down on us
yeah but they're in our same Community
this kid is [ __ ] broke as [ __ ] every
time I saw at that point she would say
hi she would say Hi here's the craziest
thing about that too
I remember I went back to the store uh
after I left to La she was still there
she remembered me she apologized and
that [ __ ] [ __ ]
wrecked me because like
I didn't realize that she knew how like
how [ __ ] up she was being towards me
and I and that's what I'm saying like
when I see that video of that kid who
got who stabbed as a young person it's
like you don't even understand like
people can change yeah you don't give
people Grace to change this is why we're
so [ __ ] up because I hate Castle
culture you don't ever here's the thing
about cancer culture that [ __ ] me up
that [ __ ] pisses me off
you are never the person that you were
five years ago yeah
when you judge somebody based on what
they do and they don't do it now that
means that they develop themselves and
they put time in themselves to be a
better person if you don't allow them to
change and you still [ __ ] on them for
stuff that they used to do why change
right why not stick to the same [ __ ]
that you always do if you do not accept
the the path that they took to become
better they might as well just do the
same [ __ ] and that's what's happening oh
if you're gonna [ __ ] on me for this war
that I said or the things that I've done
that I've already apologized for that
I've
decisively decided in my life to change
about myself but you still hate me for
it then [ __ ] it then I guess I'm going
to be the same and I've seen that yeah
and that's why cancel culture sometimes
for me is like some of the worst [ __ ]
that moment when that lady apologized to
me as an adult was [ __ ] amazing and
I'm like holy [ __ ] she just had to
understand and I bet you as much as I
was trauma that was eating her up to the
point where she had to see me as an
adult and apologize
that's amazing and you know that's the
thing I fought for my entire life
because we we moved to that role rural
area when I was in like seventh eighth
grade and I'm coming from um from a town
called Federal Way in Washington it's
actually this town or city in Washington
has the most Koreans per capita outside
of Korea that's that's what's Wild to me
about that statistic
um it like and and so from going from
there to this rural [ __ ] town
you know my I I'm in seventh grade and
I'm in band right and
I I used to be first chair trumpet at my
old junior high but now I go to this new
middle school and I have to be a last
chair trumpet right and then the guy
sitting next to me like this is my it's
our the home classes the very first
class of school the first thing somebody
everyone ever said at this school to me
was
I hate chaps
God damn and I was like well I'm not
Japanese I'm a [ __ ] yeah but he goes
good because I hate chaps
you know and my whole life there in this
[ __ ] town was me trying to have to
prove my americanness to them
but because they would never accept me
the thing I had to do was lean in more
into my Asian identity you know and and
this is where a lot of my struggle came
even like you know I moved to LA doing
my thing and come to Koreatown because
this is where I was born this is my
identity my Harmony still lives here and
all that and then I have to go back home
and work at this store like that was
such a huge like this is just a scary
moment for me to have to go back to that
like man these people are gonna treat me
like [ __ ] and whatever people like no
man like you're older now things have
changed or whatever but you know what
that confirmation bias yeah they started
treating me like [ __ ] they didn't accept
me they told me to get out of this
country and I'm and I tell them where am
I supposed to go yeah I was [ __ ] born
here you know and have you heard me
speak Korean yeah is terrible yeah but
they don't know that they just hear all
ching chong ching chong when I'm talking
to my mom yeah you know and
what I know I had a similar experience
too where
the the small black community my
community there's like six black people
yeah they accepted me because they knew
hate like where it's a struggle out here
it feels like we don't belong yeah they
they're treated us like [ __ ] you know
and so they're and I told you that that
one man with those scratchy voice he
told me like if they [ __ ] with you you
gotta [ __ ] with them back you know you
have to stand up for yourself you know
but I had an experience with one black
customer who gave me [ __ ] for like you
know stealing from the community taking
money or whatever like this guy works
hard and here I am with this whatever
and
um it got it where we and we almost came
to blows and I'm just like what what did
I do to you man what did I do and he was
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
until he left and that was that incident
I had with my um ex girlfriend at the
time where she was like I just saw two
idiots fighting you know it goes deeper
than that and so he started going to to
another store which is my friend's store
and I told him what had happened and
then so he knew the guy too and he had
to tell them hey man he's been here his
family's been here for 25 years yeah you
know they've been part of this community
like his mom is a staple in this
community they've been here yeah you
know and that had he came back
and like I was talking ice cream and
then I was same thing shocked to see him
yeah you know I was on my toes like oh
[ __ ] here we go this guy's gonna [ __ ] me
up yeah but he was like hey man I'm
sorry like I didn't know who you were
you know he was also drunk too and he's
like I had I quit drinking man like I'm
really sorry for what happened and then
I had to say yeah man like it's hard for
me to live here too because yeah these
white people are crazy out here dude
they treat me like less than they take
my dignity away daily too I don't like
it either I'm not like on that side of
the fence where I think you're less than
me yeah you know like it's a struggle
for both of us and we shook hands you
know and it became cool from there I'm a
cheek you're an N word
and you guys have embraced each other
dude Rush Hour four man like who is like
I I really do believe in humanity listen
yeah when I've done these videos where I
shat on people who do [ __ ] up things
I'm not telling you to hate them for the
rest of your life I'm talking about the
instance that happened right because
we're asking them to load like be a
[ __ ] better person yeah you just
check them I don't hate these people
right and let's say later on that they
stop doing it then cool I think that
they're good people changes the ability
to recognize when you're doing something
[ __ ] up and then changing it is the
best part about it right it's like that
is why I really do believe in The Human
Experience nowadays people don't like
The Human Experience they expect
Perfection out of everybody nobody has
nobody's [ __ ] perfect people are
evolving and growing all the time and if
you don't do that with conversation you
don't do it with Grace you don't allow
them to change then what's the whole
[ __ ] point what's the whole point of
living on this Earth because I'm not the
same person that I was when I was
younger Ed is not the same person that
he was when I first met him either yeah
we've all
through conversation through Grace being
friends you know figuring around our own
path and stuff we all became better and
we all started leveling up together
right to redeem ourselves to reconcile
our relationships with these people yeah
and I've I've I've I've had these
moments back in my past where I I hate
it you know and I've had to apologize
for these things too the amazing thing
about that person too is that he didn't
have to go out of his way to come into
your store and apologize to you yeah he
could have just felt embarrassed dealt
with his emotions himself and just left
it at that but he wanted to rectify what
he did
that's
[ __ ] beautiful yeah you know we don't
allow people disgraced anymore at all
and that is the Pinnacle of what it is
like with The Human Experience and like
I always go back to us being the church
boys that's exactly what the gospel is
it's the reconciliation of a
relationship with God but then the point
of the Gospel is towards each other yeah
how like if we can get to a point where
to Humble ourselves to repent to just
say sorry and ask for forgiveness then
the reciprocating part is to give
forgiveness yeah you know then we can
redeem our character we can redeem
ourselves we can be new people and we
can reconcile these relationships the
the saddest part what about all this too
I see this kid you know obviously lacks
a ton of foresight
you know he he lacked the part where
like things could be better he to to
Reddit AMA he thinks nothing's gonna
happen to him legally this guy is an
idiot you know because he's he's loving
he loves the bloodbath and he he thinks
he's a superhero no but that that's the
thing he thinks he's being accepted into
American Society for standing his ground
that's what he keeps saying I stood my
ground I stood my ground no you [ __ ]
try to murder somebody yeah like and or
vape cartridges you [ __ ] psychopath
that's psychotic that is not even human
it's not humane
you know and if we're trying to be
anti-racist and to destroy this it
starts in US it doesn't start with the
government by making more laws to punish
people more for their hate crimes or
whatever I mean like that [ __ ] is
Justified too but it starts with us and
us being bigger better people than the
situations we're in and that's the kind
of thing I had to step over because
trust me you know you saw me when I got
back I was a shell of myself yeah I I
was like a bombed out person my brain
was not the same because of all the
abuse I took at that store
you know but the the healing part came
out was with being able to recognize
like look I had 300 customers a gay a
day a day
sorry but I had 300 customers a day one
or two people were [ __ ] how [ __ ]
stupid is it for me to start judging all
of these white people you know the rest
of the 298 of them as the same people as
these [ __ ] methods raise this method
you know they're not that and they
supported us and they've you know come
back to our business and
like that's the stuff that I'm going to
bank on and I learned that from my mom
too like when this whole stuff was
happening like my mom was like the whole
of the BLM thing which I was kind of
surprised she was just like man this is
terrible like she was talking about like
all of her customers who always come
through and how great they are it's like
they they I wish people would see this
side because yeah we have the store
because of them you know they've come
through we have customers who have been
coming to us for [ __ ] 30 years dude
yeah my mom my mom my mom told me the uh
the other day that
she got really sad because there was a
customer that she used to see every day
um it was a daughter and their mom and
they stopped coming recently and I think
she found out that they passed away both
of them and she's met the daughter at
the time that she was like 30.
and um uh so she was like 16 up I think
they both passed away and she got super
[ __ ] sad yeah and these are people
that came every every week to our store
and they just weren't there anymore
there's she was told me that she saw a
customer that she saw when she was 12.
and now that girl is 42. yeah she's 40
[ __ ] two years old yeah you know and
she saw this kid grow up from being in
elementary school the junior high to
high school to college and then you know
having her own family and now she has
her own grandkids like like how can you
you know be a part of that community and
have zero empathy for them how can you
look at them in less than humans yeah
you know uh and that's what I like I I
hate seeing like all these [ __ ]
comments that support this kid like
these are still human beings their lives
regardless of how shitty they were being
in that moment or whatever situation
they grew up in where they felt that it
was okay to steal or whatever doesn't
mean that they should have lost their
lives or been paralyzed with [ __ ]
seven stab wounds yeah that that kid
definitely play he's he's definitely
played like games like if he's
relegating the reason why he was
comments through games he has been
imagining this moment his whole life
yeah he is a [ __ ] psychopath if you
support him in that type of sense and
not support the fact that he needs help
because he's a [ __ ] psychopath you
have some [ __ ] issues the man took a
knife and put tried to put it right into
his jugular like he was [ __ ] like a
buffalo in the wild like he was
livestock are you [ __ ] insane he was
trying to run away and you stabbed him
in the [ __ ] back yeah in his spine
that's that's that's yeah we will say it
again I want this kid in jail but here's
the thing like I'm looking at the
aftermath of it too like if we're gonna
see some foresight like it happened in
Vegas and Nevada is a red State yeah I
can imagine a a jury of his peers
you know letting him go because of what
had happened you know like if people
think that is the American way like I
feel sad for our society like that's not
okay you know I think he should he needs
help it's like like psychotic help uh he
needs and the people that are damning
you calling you an [ __ ] is [ __ ]
nuts they're calling me naive yeah like
I haven't lived through all this before
when they haven't themselves yeah it's
like you are [ __ ] insane by the like
I said 20 30 bucks worth of [ __ ] Vape
cartridges it's not worth a human life I
don't give a [ __ ] what you say yeah I
absolutely do not exclude so even that
guy I you know I beat the [ __ ] out of
him over a case of beer you know yeah
and then
um as you know time passed and I was
talking to the sheriffs I was like okay
so you know what he's going to jail and
they're like no we're taking him to the
hospital and I'm like you know yeah but
that's like the normal human reaction
you're not going to an AM ask me
anything yeah do you think I'm like hey
is it gonna die yeah it's like and then
you respond I watched a lot of Rocky
movies yeah so I was prepared like I
watch UFC every Saturday guys I mean I
do but that wasn't like my inspiration
yeah I felt terrible afterwards to be
honest I felt terrible he like there
there were other situations I could have
gone through like honestly let them go
too in a sense because it was like 20
bucks it was a 20 case of beer wow well
guys that wraps up this episode of The
Genius brain podcast hope you enjoyed
this episode uh leave in the comments
below what you think about the situation
watch that video clip I won't be able to
splice that into this video because
that's just [ __ ] intense and I do not
want to see that again like I can't I
can't look at that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] horrific
um but you can catch genius brain every
Sundays at 12 p.m uh and you can catch
Ed at edpark v p uh DM him and more hate
please I'm ready for it uh if you guys
want to cop uh the gear if you see the
hat right here secret society is my
contemporary fashion Basics brand is
something that I'm super passionate
about really just trying to [ __ ] show
people up that you know these brands are
spending making you spend 300 for [ __ ]
we can do what they do 10 times better
but at fraction of the cost
um that's what we're about G's brand
every Sundays at 12 p.m we'll see you
all next time peace peace
right now
[Music]